bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen à strasbourg nous sommes
ensemble pour 30millions d'actualité
européenne
cette semaine nous vous proposons une
enquête exceptionnelle le trafic d'êtres
humains se développe au coeur même de
l'europe reportage en albanie où nous
avons suivi des associations épaulé par
l'union européenne elle tente de venir
en aide aux jeunes victimes de ce trafic
mais d'abord l'actualité de la semaine
alors que la roumanie et la bulgarie se
sont une nouvelle fois vu refuser
l'entrée dans l'espace schengen ces
négociations neuwirth elle pas au bal
des hypocrites
quelle déception
une nouvelle fois on claque la porte de
schengen en est de la bulgarie et de la
roumanie
mais il fallait s'y attendre non depuis
le temps que ces deux pays de l'est
tambourine à la porte de l'espace et
qu'on leur refuse l'accès au saint graal
pourtant la commission et le parlement
européens estimaient que sofia et
bucarest avait rempli le cahier des
charges que techniquement ils pouvaient
prétendre à devenir les 23e et 24e pays
de la zone
mais non les ministres de l'intérieur
des pays membres n'ont pas voulu entre
autres l'allemagne et les pays-bas pas à
la hauteur des roumains et les bulgares
trop corruptible doté d'un système
judiciaire défaillant pas capables de
contrôler les frontières extérieures pas
apte à juguler l'exode de sa population
vers l'eldorado à l'ouest un peu sévère
non alors cet espace schengen le bal des
hypocrites
et nous voilà de retour sur le plateau
d' europe hebdo au parlement européen à
strasbourg pour évoquer cette question
des frontières extérieures de l'europe
et donc de l'espace schengen nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau sylvie guillaume
bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc membre de
la commission justice et affaires
intérieures entre autres libertés
civiles pardon et justice et vice
présidente du groupe socialiste et
démocrate
alors est-ce que cet espace schengen
finalement c'est pas un petit peu le bal
des hypocrites
c'est une bonne formule effectivement en
tout cas c'est de l'hypocrisie et la
recherche de boucs émissaires et on
assume pas certain nombre de décisions
et c'est ça qui se passe effectivement
en ce moment c'est bien l'idée générale
de l'hypocrisie d'un certain nombre
d'états membres qui considère que
finalement il y à des états de première
ou de deuxième classe dans les lions
donc pour appeler un petit peu le
contexte à nos téléspectateurs
en 2007 la rue mène la roumanie pardon
et la bulgarie entre dans l'union avec
l'idée derrière d'adhérer à l'espace
schengen sauf que depuis finalement on
leur a retoqué la porte presque pas
trois fois de mémoire dont une très
récemment dorny très récemment jusqu'à
quand ça va durer ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que dans l'intervalle depuis 2007
où on pouvait considérer à juste titre
ou un mauvais titre que les deux états
n'étaient pas prêts ils ont fait des
efforts extrêmement sérieux pour se
mettre à jour vis-à-vis des critères qui
ont été demandés à tous les états au
moment d'entrer dans schengen et donc
ces états ont modernisé leurs systèmes
de surveillance ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour se mettre à jour
technologiquement
ils sont même d'ailleurs probablement
plus tard mais technologiquement si le
matériel faisait l'ensemble de la
décision ils sont plus armés que
certains autres états ce qui coince
maintenant c'est qu'effectivement sur
fond de crise économique avec des
mouvements de population un certain
nombre d'états considèrent qu'ils ne
sont pas encore prêts et remettre des
étapes supplémentaires à la roumanie et
à la bulgarie
comme si ça ne suffisait pas moi je
considère et le parlement dans son
ensemble a considéré que la bulgarie et
la roumanie vis-à-vis des critères qui
leur étaient demandées ont répandu à ce
qui leur était ce qu'ils étaient
ces serres pour entrer dans l'espace
schengen donc il ya d'autres raisons et
c'est pour ça que vous aviez raison de
dire que c'est de l'hypocrisie
donc là la raison effectivement vous
l'avez évoqué c'est la possibilité d'une
j'ouvre les guillemets d'une invasion
puisque ce sont les termes qui ont été
utilisés notamment par les britanniques
par la presse britannique entre autres
d'une invasion de roumains et de
bulgares sur l'europe de l'ouest est ce
que c'est un risque finalement est-ce
que c'est pas déjà le cas vu que les
roumains et les bulgares ont déjà la
liberté de circulation
et justement ça n'est pas tout à fait ça
la situation ce qui est reproché à
priori à ces deux états qui sont en
bordure de l'union européenne c'est
d'avoir des frontières extérieures trop
poreuse et de ne pas savoir faire la
police aux frontières de l'union
et donc de laisser rentrer des filles
des gens de manière clandestine dans
l'union s'est pas tellement là l'entrée
des bulgares et des roumains dans le
reste de l'union parce qu'effectivement
la libre circulation exista n'est pas la
problématique c'est d'autres types de
plus emblématiques plus exactement mais
c'est en gros ce qui est ce qui pose
problème un certain nombre d'états
membres
c'est le fait que la bulgarie et la
roumanie n'ont pas ne sont pas
suffisamment sérieuse d'une part dans la
corruption et d'autre part dans la
porosité de leurs frontières
mais cette porosité de frontières c'est
aussi la sphère de toute l'europe on ne
peut pas jurer mende et aux bulgares aux
roumains aux grecs ou aux turcs de
s'occuper des frontières de l'europe
sauf que les frontières sont plus ou
moins poreuse et plus ou moins
dangereuses a traversé l'europe a bouclé
les entrées en méditerranée qu'il
s'agisse de l'entrée par l'espagne puis
à part la méditerranée il ya eu l'année
dernière et c'est aussi un sujet avec
les printemps arabes l'arrivée à
lampedusa et donc de réaction de
monsieur berlusconi et sarkozy qui ont
posé des problématiques schengen et puis
les barrières à l'entrée se sont
déportés jusqu'à la grèce qui reste
maintenant
le principal bleus d'entrée de l'union
mais demain si effectivement la bulgarie
et la roumanie rentrer dans schengen
s'ouvre de nouvelles frontières
extérieures de l'union qui peuvent
éventuellement permettre l'entrée sur le
territoire schengen donc c'est ça qui
pose problème à ses états membres
alors vous l'avez évoqué silvio
berlusconi à nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
avait voulu remettre en question donc
les frontières extérieures et l'entrée
de certains pays dans schengen on voit
finalement que malgré l'arrivée de
françois hollande au pouvoir la position
de la france n'a pas évolué sur cette
question vous en tant que socialiste est
ce que vous en pensez
ce que nicolas sarkozy et silvio
berlusconi aurait remis en cause
s'étaient pas les frontières extérieures
s'était il voulait avoir de nouvelles
règles pour l'entrée et donc ils avaient
érigé de leur propre fait de nouvelles
règles prétextant un afflux après les
printemps à il avait voulu aussi à un
moment remettre en question l'espace
schengen exactement parce par ce biais
là en remettant des frontières là où il
n'y avait pas lieu d'être et où ils ne
pouvaient pas décider seul
la situation est très très différentes
maintenant dans la position de l'état
français puisque les dernières
rencontres entre monsieur comptable
premier ministre romain et avec le
premier ministre français ont montré
qu'il y avait une évolution possible sur
la question de l'entrée la roumanie et
la bulgarie
donc je crois qu'on progresse il faut
faire les choses dans un bon calendrier
avec de bonnes résolutions mais je crois
que les choses progressent en tout cas
c'est selon vous c'est pas assez au sens
où les propositions qui ont été faites à
la roumanie et à la bulgarie ne sont pas
ne sont pas correct du point de vue des
critères demandés a saisi sur un jeu
duke finalement on a remis un petit peu
de nouvelles règles au milieu de la côte
de la partie de foot si je puis dire
d'où l'idée effectivement et j'espère
qu'on pourra du point de vue des
autorités françaises être vraiment sûr
ces règles de droit de remettre
exactement les bons critères c'est ce
que vous demandez à françois hollande et
au premier
je pense qu'ils sont dans cette
perspective là c'est en tout cas ce qui
est prévu de discuter dans le prochain
conseil jive donc on aura sûrement des
éléments complémentaires à ce moment là
il ya une autre question qui intéresse
sur schengen en ce moment c'est la
cécilia maelström qui l'a mise à
l'agenda c'est la question des
frontières intelligente entre guillemets
l'idée ce serait de faire un espèce de
passeports biométriques ou une carte
biométrique pour les visiteurs qui
viendrait de l'extérieur de l'europe en
europe
les verts y voient une forme de big
brother 2.0 est ce que c'est votre avis
oui c'est un aspect des choses et vous
savez que globalement la question des
données et des passages des frontières
avec la biométrie est un problème en soi
moi ce que je trouve un autre aspect de
la question que je trouve assez
problématique aussi c'est ce sont des
frontières intelligente pour les gens
riches et bien portant d'une certaine
manière et moi je tout à fait consciente
que faciliter le passage d'hommes
d'affaires d'étudiants qui font beaucoup
de trajets qui font beaucoup
d'allers-retours est une problématique
en soi qui doit être résolu et pourquoi
pas facilité les choses de ce point de
vue ça ne les vend rien une réflexion
plus large sur la manière dont l'europe
accueille ou pas ou quelles sont les
règles pour le reste des gens qui
migrent et là ça fait là aussi deux
classes différentes
en gros vous
vous pointez une europe à deux vitesses
une nouvelle fois bon bah écoute et
merci beaucoup en attendant d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
nous on continue sur les questions des
frontières mais cette fois-ci de la zone
euro bizarrement alors que la zone euro
est en pleine crise la lettonie vient de
faire acte de candidature on en parle
tout de suite avec aurélie da face au
travers du zapping des télévisions
étrangères
un dix-huitième pays dans la zone euro
l'idée fait son chemin depuis déjà
quelques temps jean ping wei wu à wigan
shopping au marché central de riga tout
est payé en lattes
mais la monnaie pourrait bientôt changer
pour l'euro après avoir expérimenté
l'une des pires récessions en europe
l'économie lettone se redresse et biz
maintenant à rejoindre la zone euro inde
en outre argué toujours indie games est
alors attractive l'eurozone
les députés européens les tons semblent
divisés sur la question
je suis totalement pour il ya plusieurs
raisons à cela d'abord nous sommes
profondément intégré en europe
nos exportations vers l'europe
représente environ 77%
je ne pense pas que ce soit le moment
d'adhérer à la zone euro en pleine crise
nous devons attendre au moins jusqu'en
interros la décision relève maintenant
de la commission européenne
réponse en juillet mais déjà sept
experts expriment un avis positif
la lettonie a fait des progrès
significatifs pour ajuster son économie
revenir en tête parmi les états membres
être compétitive donc je pense que
probablement en termes de critères
les chances sont très bonnes pour que la
commission délivre un verdict positif
cette année
et pour évoquer cette possible entrée de
la lettonie dans la zone euro c'est jean
sébastien lefebvre qui nous a rejoint
bonjour vous êtes journaliste à euractiv
un portail d'information sur l'actualité
européenne
alors c'est assez est ou non parce que
la lettonie est un pays en crise on
pensait que c'est un pays en crise
pourquoi est ce qu'elles demandent son
adhésion à la zone euro
la donne était un pays en crise en 2008
ce au moment de la crise des subprimes
en fait l'économie s'est écroulé elle a
perdu 21 % de son pib qui équivaut à peu
près ce qu'a perdu la grèce en mer en
six mois six mois un an aujourd'hui elle
va beaucoup mieux à 5% de croissance
un chiffre dont tout le monde rêve
exactement mais bon elle repart elle
part de loin finalement on peut dire ça
et du coup aujourd'hui l'ambition des
politiques lettons et deux d'entre eux
dans la zone euro mais ç'a toujours été
le cas finalement avant la crise ils
voulaient aussi intégré c'est une sorte
de fixette chez eux et depuis très
longtemps déjà le cours de la monnaie
lettone est indexé sur l'euro est bloqué
donc ça veut dire que le il ya une
parité fixe et l'adhésion en fait de la
lettonie ils ont toujours eu ce but en
tête en tête c'est dans les traités
toute façon ils doivent à terme y
rentrer
mais c'est vraiment un objectif
prioritaire chez eux et même durant la
crise de 2008 ils n'ont pas touché la
parité de la monnaie
ça veut dire que ils ont préféré couper
dans les salaires faire des coups de
faire de l'austérité plutôt que
d'évaluer la monnaie ou faire des choses
comme ça donc c'est vraiment un objectif
à terme est ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est que alors que la zone euro
finalement est en crise
on a un pays qui cherche un petit peu
quoi c'est une protection finalement
d'entrer dans cette dans cette zone
les partisans pour 10 de toute façon
déjà très intégré ça peut qu'être
bénéfique pour la lettonie d'avoir des
échanges facilités avec la zone euro
effectivement et après on peut voir dans
l'imaginaire letton aussi un attachement
très fort à l'europe par rapport à son
voisin russe donc c'est une sorte d'
ancrage définitif au sein de l'union
européenne
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres pays comme la
lettonie qui sont dans la même et
l'estonie qui a rentré dernièrement
aussi
c'était en 2012 le la lituanie va suivre
donc les trois pays baltes finalement
veulent toujours rentrée et puis à la
pologne qui commence à réfléchir
mais la pologne c'est à la fois quelque
chose d' économique mais aussi politique
c'est la pologne ne veut pas être mise à
la marge de l'union européenne donc elle
dit si on veut continuer au coeur de
l'intégration européenne il faut qu'on
rejoigne la zone euro donc il ya un
débat qui commence à se lancer avec le
premier ministre donald tusk qui dit il
faut qu'on faut qu'on y aille
il sert pas quand ils sont encore un peu
prudent mais la pologne à terme va dans
les années à venir et pour la lettonie
qu'est ce qu'on pense les institutions
européennes est ce qu'on peut quel est
le calendrier finalement alors là il
faut que la banque centrale européenne
et la commission européenne analyse la
situation en lettonie mais si on prend
un rapport qui a été publié en mai 2012
par la commission européenne
on voit qu'elle est quand même un petit
peu sceptique en disant tous les
critères ne sont pas là niveau
d'endettement ça va la dette publique
c'est 40 % du pib donc ça c'est en
dessous des critères de maastricht se
pose la question de la façon la
stabilité des prix
ça c'est pas très clair donc il va
falloir attendre mais les lettons sont
très optimistes quand on écoute les
ministres et le premier ministre il
c'est sûr ils vont avoir ri favorable
ils vont entrer en 2014 et c'est donc là
ça va ça va être après les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement de la zone euro qui à
la fin devant donner leur aval donc ça
reste une décision politique qu'il faut
se rappeler que la grèce est rentrée
dans la zone euro en 2008
donc la question c'est voilà foot non il
faut bien faire attention à qui avec des
mécanismes de contrôle y voilà alors
justement vous parlez de la grèce on a
la dent aux temps forts de l'actualité
on parle budget en parle pas qu on pas
qu de la crise alors est-ce qu'on est
sortis d'affaires finalement ça dépend
laquelle le crise en fait la crise
financière on a même pour l'instant est
en sommeil
les marchés sont à peu près calme on a
eu quelques soubresauts avec les
élections en italie et dans l'ensemble
ça va à peu près aujourd'hui la crise en
quelque sorte est descendu d'un étage
n'est plus financière l es économique et
social on voit que le chômage continue à
augmenter les perspectives de croissance
ne sont pas réjouissantes pour les deux
années à venir
donc finalement la crise et hélas sauf
qu'elle est beaucoup plus diffuse on a
pu les temps forts de
l'automne 2011 et de l'hiver 2012 mais
elle est finalement le quotidien de tous
les européens et dernière question
rapidement on voit que l'impasse
politique en italie joue peut-être un
petit peu sur les marchés la france
vient d'annoncer qu'elle ne respecterait
pas les 3% de déficit
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un effet
rebond de cette crise du coup ses skis
certains pensent après faut savoir est
ce que la crise en italie va perdurer
parce que finalement les députés de pépé
griot vont pas fuit accepté de voter la
confiance pour un gouvernement de gauche
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes donc le
fait que la france respecte pas le
déficit à 3% cette année devrait pas
avoir forcément beaucoup de conséquences
c'est même la commission est quand même
assez souple on a vu que olli rehn
il ya un mois quand il a fait des
prévisions de croissance en trois
semaines a dit que bout ils vont ils
vont pas les sanctionner tout de suite
peut-être empruntant mais on verra et
finalement pu totalement la france s'en
sort pas si mal voilà et puis plus tôt
en 2014 parce que bon si on coupe encore
dans les dépenses qu'est ce qui va se
passer au point de vue la croissance où
ça va être encore pire
la commission commence finalement à se
poser en interne intérieur des questions
sur est-ce que l'austérité forcément la
réponse à tout merci jean sébastien bach
fait d'avoir été parmi nous pour nous
expliquer tout ça nous on continue notre
voyage direction l'albanie et ira n'ya
plus exactement si ce pays ne fait pas
partie de l'union européenne il obtient
des fonds notamment pour lutter contre
la traite des êtres humains avant de
retrouver kathia gilder et son invité
direction tirana avec fabrice qu'une est
éliminé à l'ailé estelle boileau
le standing au chicon famille qu ils ne
mangeraient pour nous
cheveux secs soit riche c'est la
dernière campagne d'une ong albanaise
contre la traite des êtres humains le
dernier symbole de la mobilisation
contre ces trafics hissant en albanie
l'exploitation des enfants ou la
prostitution ont longtemps été des
sujets tabous ya un problème récurrent
dans un pays où le salaire moyen ne
dépasse pas 200 euros par mois
depuis quelques années les choses
changent et la lutte contre ces trafics
s'organise depuis son petit bureau de la
capitale tirana
daniela coordonne l'action des ong
dédiée à l'enfance un vaste réseau
d'alerté dead à la réinsertion parti
d'un constat
ici il n'y a pas de service public qui
aide les enfants en difficultés à se
réinsérer
c'est à nous à alger d'assurer cette
mission il faut réintégrer ces jeunes
victimes de violences le trafic ou de
travaux forcés et comme l'état ne le
fait pas notre travail est très
important dans leur travail au quotidien
les ong mettent l'accent sur la
prévention exemple dans cet immeuble au
coeur d'un quartier très défavorisé de
tirana un accueil de jour pour des
enfants en grande précarité et un
soutien pour leurs familles les enfants
qu'à l'être on a appris aujourd'hui
chaque jour une cinquantaine d'enfants
déscolarisés se retrouvent autour de ces
tables pour des cours ou des activités
une alternative à la rue ce sont pour la
plupart des enfants livrés à eux mêmes
et qui vivent dans une grande pauvreté
ils sont tous des victimes potentielles
de n'importe quel trafic ou souvent
utilisés par leurs familles pour gagner
de l'argent
il s'appelle beyram berti ou franco ils
ont entre 4 et 15 ans tous racontent la
même histoire les mêmes difficultés
familiales et travaille et fait partie
de leur quotidien
moi je vends des noisettes aux gens et
après je donne l'argent a maintenant
quand on rentre à la maison
moi quand je suis dehors je cherche du
fer où je vais sur internet et le faire
que je trouve
je le vends pour ma famille eux sont
restés à tirana mais parfois les enfants
seraient loués ou envoyés au kosovo en
macédoine en grèce pour travailler
quelqu'un a vu la maîtrise ioana pour
sony la masse ati certains réseaux
criminels cible les familles pauvres et
profite de ce trafic
après plusieurs années à la direction de
ce centre d'accueil
elle voit la situation s'améliorait
lentement je pense qu'il reste beaucoup
de difficultés il y à certaines
problématiques que l'on n'arrive
toujours pas à résoudre à cause de la
bureaucratie
même s'il est à adopter des lois
récemment le chemin est encore long pour
que l'on réussisse ensemble à trouver
des réponses aux problèmes de ses
enfants et de leurs familles
sous la pression de l'union européenne
l'albanie a en effet adopté une série de
lois mises en place des plans d'actions
depuis une dizaine d'années pour lutter
contre le trafic d'êtres humains
l'homme clé du dispositif le vice
ministre de l'intérieur
face aux critiques ne redonne d'oka
réclame du temps la coopération avec les
ong c'est vrai et à améliorer pour
réinsérer les victimes dans la société
il faut aussi que l'on perfectionne
notre cadre juridique
même si le cadre existant me semble déjà
efficace doit travailler à l'adapter aux
standards européens et ses carences sont
encore plus criantes en matière de
prostitution
c'est du moins le constat fait par les
ong comme celle d'ariel à mitry les
femmes sont victimes de stigmatisation
par la société albanaise et les
structures de réintégration manque
seulement 5 sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour des raisons de sécurité impossible
de filmer ses centres d'accueil pour
fait leur intégration à début les
victimes mais sans lui besoin d'une
maison d'une place pour dormir
la sécurité pour la nourriture et après
construit un projet de réintégration
et si toujours c'est difficile trouver
une place que ce soit pour les enfants
ou pour les femmes victimes de trafic
la solution passe par l'éducation
l'europe soutient certains programmes de
sensibilisation à tirana comme dans le
reste de l'allemagne
mais dans un pays où l'on manque de tout
les trafiquants ont encore une longueur
d'avancé
c'est incroyable mais c'est bien la
réalité vous l'avez vu avec ce reportage
tourné en albanie par fabrice qu'une
haie on en parle avec notre invité
véronique mathieu bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes députée européenne
d'origine française ou travailler sur
les questions de justice et de sécurité
et vous êtes membre notamment de la crim
la commission spéciale sur la
criminalité organisée la corruption et
le blanchiment de capitaux
alors on vous avez regardez ce reportage
c'est assez incroyable de voir cette
forme d esclavage moderne au 21ème
siècle
est ce que finalement la lutte contre
ces réseaux criminels mais n'est pas
vaine on se dit en voyant ça que
malheureusement les trafiquants ou
toujours une longueur d'avancé sur les
états ou les ou sur les polices oui
malheureusement c'est un petit peu le
canon c'est un certain nombre d'états
qui frappe d'ailleurs à la porte de
l'europe puisque vous savez que
l'albanie est candidate pour intégrer
l'union européenne et c'est un petit peu
la force que nous avons nous au sein de
l'union c'est que nous essayons de
mettre l'allemagne et au pas donc la
mafia est très présente en albanie et
nous essayons de lutter contre la mafia
avec le poste de candidate à l'union
alors quelles sont les racines du mal si
je puis dire est ce que c'est un
problème de l'état albanais qui manquent
on l'a vu des structures d'aidé moyens
ou peut-être même de la volonté
politique pour traiter ce problème
puisque c'est la conséquence de la
pauvreté qui force tous et où certaines
familles à qui mais certains enfants
dans les mains des criminels
quelle est la cause de ça les facteurs
sont multiples il y à déjà effectivement
un manque de structures sociales
politiques de structures au niveau de
l'état bien évidemment mais il ya aussi
un problème de niveau de vie et on ne
sait bien les mafias se développe quand
le niveau de vie est très bas on le voit
bien d'ailleurs même au niveau de
l'union européenne en ce moment alors
que nous connaissons une crise très
importante et bien la mafia se développe
parce que les gens ont peur les gens
sont dans une situation très incertaine
et la mafia est en train de gagner du
terrain un petit peu partout alors
particulièrement en albanie parce que la
mafia est très forte elle a d'ailleurs
des connexions au niveau mondial et on
vous le savez bien l'allemagne et projet
l'italie où la mafia est très importante
et la mafia albanaise à une connexion
très importante avec la mafia italienne
est-ce que l'union européenne avec ses
moyens à la possibilité de lutter contre
ces réseaux criminels et comment oui
déjà
on a des structures pour lutter contre
cela on a des agences européennes par
exemple europol qui est une sorte de fbi
européen qui est de plus en plus
performants parce qu'on lui donne les
moyens on a eu juste qu'ils sont d une
autre agence européenne qui met en place
des équipes comme une enquête et on sait
par exemple qu'europol avec des belles
prises avec qui concerne la mafia
albanaise on sait par exemple qu'à
mulhouse à l'automne dernier europol a
réussi une belle prise ce qui concerne
la mafia albanaise fut il est vrai que
s'il est tout à fait parce qu'il ya une
bonne connexion qui est organisé par 1re
pole donc bon c'est on a des résultats
concrets mais ça n'est encore pas
suffisant on ne peut pas tout réussir un
coup mais est ce que vous pensez pas que
ce pour lutter contre ce problème ça
passe aussi par des actions de
prévention sur le terrain par exemple
même dans l'est dans les camps de
réfugiés mais on sait que les
trafiquants profitent des des situations
de conflits de pour asseoir leur emprise
sur les plus faibles
il faut le faire mais pour cela bien sûr
on à la difficulté de la prévention
alors il faudrait qu'on puisse être
présent partout les ong on l'a vu dans
votre reportage font évidemment un
travail de terrain un travail de fourmi
qui est extrêmement important et ça
passe aussi par l'éducation des enfants
on espère qu'avec cette cette prévention
par l'éducation évidemment la mafia va
reculer un petit peu mais c'est sûr
vraiment du très long terme
ça c'est clair très long terme c'est à
quel horizon prend lé petit vous le
voyez bien très petit alors en éduquant
les gamins on espère que ça va reculer
mais c'est ce que tous les pays
européens jouent le jeu
est ce qu'il ya une prise de conscience
de tous les pays européens par rapport à
cette préoccupation
on parle bien ici de traite des êtres
humains et on est au 21ème siècle la
traite des êtres humains c'est vraiment
on le sent une spécialisation un petit
peu dans la mafia les mafias qui sont
présentes en albanie les mafias dans les
balkans ça on le constate très nettement
l'impression rien ce reportage que
l'état albanais jouent le jeu on a vu
que l'europe était présente sur place on
a un petit bureau des petits moyens on
n'a pas l'impression que le lait-
albanel la suivent si je puis dire
l'état albanais soit vraiment intégrer
l'union européenne et ça va être la
condition sine qua none on a mis en a
mis les conditions drastiques pour
l'intégration elle d'ailleurs l'albanie
n'a encore pas son statut de candidate
on a mis un certain nombre de douze
points très importants sur les questions
sociales des questions de démocratie des
questions de criminalité organisée ça
c'est une question sur laquelle le
conseil ne cédera pas et on va voir si
les si les résultats
et si le et si la volonté de l'état
albanais n'est pas au rendez-vous et
bien le conseil ne cédera pas sur le
statut de candidat après le statut de
candidat il y à l'intégration l'union
n'en que vous voyez c'est un chemin qui
est très long et il aura le talent et
albanais aura le temps de progresser
dans sa lutte contre la criminalité
organisée
particulièrement la traite des êtres
humains la traite est la prostitution
des êtres humains
après il ya le trafic de drogue le
trafic de drogue également la mafia
albanaise est malheureusement très en
pointe aussi avec des connexions vers
les pays européens mais également vers
les états unis
et vers le sud aussi de 2 vers l'afrique
également on vous dit que cette forme
d'exploitation sont en hausse au coeur
même de l'europe de l'union au coeur
même de l'europe
tout à fait on sépare on sait qu'ils
passent par la grèce par l'italie donc
ces cdd font malheureusement avec des
frontières qui ne sont nos frontières
européennes qui sont encore par
suffisamment bien bien né c'est aussi ça
l'une des quiz merci beaucoup
véronique mathieu d'avant était avec
nous pour commenter ce reportage c'est
la fin de cette émission je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine à
bruxelles avec françois beaudonnet d'ici
là très bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires